[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sens public votre
rendez-vous quotidien de débats de
chronique et de reportage sur Public
Sénat vous connaissez la promesse de
l'émission donne du sens à l'actualité
vous proposez des clés de compréhension
des mutation de notre société avec au
sommaire de ce 14 novembre la loi
immigration adoptée par le Sénat elle
entérine les concession de Gérald
armanin OLR et au centriste mais ce
texte sans doute le plus dur de la 5e
République sur ces questions migratoires
peut-il obtenir une majorité à
l'Assemblée l'aile gauche de la macronie
peut-elle laisser passer la suppression
de l'aide médicale d'État ou encore
l'abandon de l'article 3 sur les métiers
en ttention réponse dans une minute et
puis pour notre second débat cette
question les actes terroristes et les
crimes de guerre commis depuis 5
semaines au Proche Orient seront-ils
juger un collectif d'avocats a saisi la
Cour pénale internationale en espérant
qu'elle instruise à la fois fois les
horreurs commises par le Hamas le 7
octobre et les civils tués par milliers
par les frappes israéliennes dans la
bande de Gaza nous on est là d'abord
pour faire le travail d'avocat vis-à-vis
de la cour vis-à-vis du procureur et de
lui dire qu'on a vu ce qui se passait et
que ça justifie la plainte pour
génocide comment mener une telle enquête
Israël a-t-elle outrepassé son droit à
riposter quand doit-on parler de
génocide ou de crime contre l'humanité
réponse avec nos experts tout à l'heure
mais d'abord on détaille que contient ce
texte immigration voté dans l'après-midi
par le Sénat avec audre
Vaz après une semaine de vif débat le
Sénat adopte en première lecture une
version profondément remagée du projet
de loi immigration pour l'adoption 210
contre 115 le Sénat a donc
[Applaudissements]
adopté àe applaudissement à droite de
l'hémicycle car ce texte a été largement
durci par la majorité sénatoriale droite
et centre se sont accordés pour
supprimer l'aide médicale d'État
instaurer des quotas d'immigration
économique ou encore supprimer pendant 5
ans l'accès aux allocations familiales
des nouveaux arrivants sur le territoire
mais surtout l'article 3 qui prévoyait
une régularisation automatique pour les
étrangers exerçant dans des métier ou
zone géographique en tension a été
supprimé remplacé par une régularisation
cas par cas après validation du préfet
des modifications F stigé par la gauche
sénatoriale qui a refusé de voter le
texte votre texte mesdames et messieurs
de la majorité sénatoriale reprend
consciencieusement en s'alignant avec
les propositions du Front National et de
Marine Le Pen sur chacun des thèmes
évoqués lors de l'examen de ce projet de
loi après le vote du Sénat l'étape de
l'Assemblée s'annonce compliquée sachaer
le président de la commission des lois a
déjà prévenu il réintroduira l'article 3
qui porte sur la régularisation des
travailleurs sans papier dans les
métiers entention on voit bien qu'il y a
un grand détricotage que s prête à faire
l'Assemblée nationale bah les choses
seront claires ça sera plus Lefin ça
sera à nouveau un texte dur en même
temps il est hors de question d'y
souscrire et j'attends moi de nos
députés la plus grande fermeté la balle
est désormais dans le camp de la
majorité présidentielle qui évolue donc
sur une ligne de crête pour faire
adopter son projet de loi
imigration et on va voir à quel point ce
texte immigration cette loi peut-être un
facteur de division au sein des
différentes familles politiques avec
Anne Charline Bina bonsoir vous êtes
constitutionnaliste bienvenue à vous
Florent vadio bonsoir et bienvenue
président de l'éérie et enseignant à
Sciences Po Jean Daniel Levi bonsoir et
bienvenue vous êtes directeur délégué de
Haris interactive et laticia crupa
bonsoir Léticia éditorialiste politique
bienvenue à vous je commence par
peut-être le contenu du texte charine
Bina est-ce que vous diriez que tel
qu'il a été voté hein cet après-midi au
Sénat c'est je disais ça en titre l'un
des plus durs de la 5e République alors
ça dépend parce que en réalité on a fait
qu'évoluer en matière d'immigration et
il y a eu un espèce de coup de tonner
une un très grand épisode en matière
d'immigration qui a été la loi de 93 où
précisément on a eu d'ailleurs la
première jurisprudence et la seule un
petit peu constitutionnelle qui a posé
les grands principes parce qu'on avait
un gouvernement qui voulait essayer
d'aller très loin et qui a pour le coup
été retoqué par la Haute instance en
matière de droits fondamentaux donc il y
a eu des périodes RPR où le discours a
été parfois un petit peu encore plus dur
peut-être que celui qu'on connaît à
l'heure actuelle mais c'est vrai que la
pratique des lois immigration a ensuite
plutôt été assouplie même si je crois
que on oublie souvent de rappeler que
l'ADN du macronisme en matière
d'immigration n'est pas toute neuve
sortie de cette loi- làà mais aussi de
la loi colon hein de 2018 qui là aussi
était quand même particulièrement dure
je pense notamment au délet de recours
aux compétences de l'ofpr où on avait
quand même beaucoup durci aussi
dispositif donc oui elle est dure
surtout avec cette sortie sénatoriale
c'est vrai que on se rend compte que les
concessions faites au OLR sont ici
totalement apparente visible c'est plus
du tout le en même temps de la réforme
des retraites on a un texte qui s'est
droitisé complètement dans sa
philosophie il y a plus la jambe gauche
donc c'est quand même dire quelque chose
et on a accepté toutes les concessions
au coup par coup Gérald Darmanin qui
nous dit quand même je ne trahille pas
mes convictions ça prouve quand même
qu'il y a eu un peu un doute sur ces
questions dans ces différentes nuits de
discussion et euh voilà quelque chose
qui ressort de du texte d'alliance et de
compromis nécessaire ce qui nous change
un petit peu des épisodes précédents en
matière législative Florent vadiillot on
entendait Bruno rotillot le patron des
des des sénateurs LR évoquer le en même
temps macronien sur ces questions
d'immigration est-ce que pour vous en
tout cas dans cette première version
Gérald armanin le minist de l'Intérieur
a en quelque sorte enterré le en même
temps macronien sur ce texte alors au
niveau du du Sénat il a de faites
enterré puisque le texte du Gouvernement
et le texte sorti du Sénat n'est
vraiment pas le même et de très loin
donc de fait on peut considérer que par
effet de relief le texte adopté avec
avis favorable du Gouvernement et le
texte défendu n'est plus exactement le
même et il l' d'ailleurs lui même dit
puisque c'est pas exactement le texte
que le gouvernement avait porté donc
évidemment après je demande àoir le
Géral d'armanin à l'Assemblée nationale
et et et je pense d'ailleurs que les
avis de sagesse ou les avis favorables
que Darmanin Géral Darmanin a pu donner
aussi sén lui donne en réalité des
marges de négociation à l'Assemblée
nationale notamment sur les éléments sur
lesquels il avait prononcé un sagesse et
il va falloir composer une autre
majorité à l'Assemblée nationale et pour
l'instant c'est une équation impossible
parce que l'adjonction d'un élément pour
construire une majorité à l'Assemblée
vous prive d'un autre parfois chez vous
parfois chez les autres donc je je je je
veux voir ce ce Géral daranin Assemblée
nationale pour voir s'il ne rétablis pas
un peu dans même temps ou si NZ pas
contre un on y reviendra en détail sur
cette marche de manœuvre Jean-Daniel
Levi les Français ét é-il demandeur d'un
texte aussi dur quand même sur les
questions migratoires alors en fait il y
a deux aspects c'est que quand on leur
pose la question et qu'on les interroge
sur un de dispositions qui peut être
évoqué dans le casadre des discussions
pour la plupart d'entre elles ils sont
favorables mais extrêmement favorables
le deuxème aspect c'est que quand on
regarde finement les études d'opinion
mais pas forcément uniquement les plus
récentes la question migratoire n'a
jamais été en tête des préoccupations
des Français ni même des assignations à
agir alors pour être plus précis c'est
un des sujets les plus vivant d'un point
de vue d'opinion et quand vous regardez
les électeurs qui sont globalement de
plus à gauche possible voir même jusqu'à
l'électorat d'Emmanuel Macron inclus la
question migratoire est en milieu ou en
queue de tableau des préoccupations ou
des points sur lesquels ils disent le
gouvernement doit agir ça vient quoi 11
12 même 17e position en revanche quand
vous allez à droite de l'chqu politique
et comprend la dernière élection
présentielle qui va de Valérie PCR
jusqu'à éc Zemour c'est une progression
absolument onê en terme de hiérarchie
dans les préoccupations et dans les
assignations à agir à l'égard du
gouvernement c'était la première des
motivations de vote d'ailleurs de
l'électorat d'Éric Zemour la 4e de
l'électorat de Valérie pcrè par exemple
la 2è de celle de de Marine Le Pen donc
il s'agit d'un des sujets qui d'un point
de vue d'opinion est le plus clivant et
avec la pour le coup un point sur lequel
Emmanuel Macron ne cherche pas
complètement à flatter entre guillemets
son cœur d'électorat de premier tour
parce que effectivement si on regarde
plus globalement à l'une de vos étude
sur motivation de vote des électeurs
lors d'élection présidentielle toute
famille politique confondu on est bien
d'accord ça vient en 4e position
seulement c'est le pouvoir d'achat en 1
la santé en deux retraite juste derrière
et l'immigration à à
28 % est-ce que c'est un je reste avec
vous est-ce que c'est une parce que on
va finalement voir que les divisions il
y en a il y en a au sein de LR on en
parlera un peu plus tard il y en a au
sein de la macronie est-ce que c'est un
un texte qui Clive beaucoup les Français
qui absolument oui c'est un texte qui cl
en en tout cas c'est un texte sur
lesquel il y a des attendus qui sont
très nettes de la part des électeurs de
droite et qui sont qui suscitent une
forme de doute d'interrogation de la
part de l'électorat de gauche donc c'est
mais par exemple pardon interrompe le le
le l'article 3 qui a été finalement on
va dire dégommé pardon de d'être aussi
trivial par la majorité LR et et Union
centriste de du Sénat il était aussi si
j'en crois les sondages approuvé par les
Français il était approuvé absolument
par les Français au N en gros d'une
forme de réalisme économique en disant
on est face à une situation attention on
n plus du tout dans les années 90 on
s'en rappelle il y avait des
mobilisations en faveur de ceux qui
d'ailleurs à l'époque étaient désignés
comme étant des sans papiers il y avait
une mobilisation qui existait
aujourd'hui elle n'existe quasiment plus
c'est plus une forme de réalisme entre
guillemets économique qui traverse les
Français c'est-à-dire que les électeurs
de droite te disent globalement ça
permet d'avoir une forme d'activité un
maintien auprès des secteurs qui sont
les plus en difficulté pour avoir de
l'attractivité à l'égard des salariés et
à gauche en disant il y a une forme de
justice sont des personnes qui
travaillent qui payent leurs impôts qui
participent aux cotisation sociale et
donc dans ce contexte là le fait qu' est
une forme de régularisation leur
apparaît comme étant plutôt positive
alors cette loi immigration
atteindra-t-elle ses objectif certains
en doute comme le sénateur communiste
Yan
brossa tout le Paris sur lequel repose
cet ensemble de disposition est
totalement faux votre Paris c'est qu'en
dégradant les conditions d'accueil vous
dissuaderez les étrangers de venir sur
notre sol ce Paris est faux ils
viendront mais ils viendront dans des
conditions d'accueil qui qui seront
déplorables qui seront lamentables et ce
sera du fait des dispositions qui ont
été votées dans le cadre de cette de
cette discussion la
réalité c'est que le mirage c'est vous
qui le présentez en faisant croire que
l'immigration cessera ou se réduira
drastiquement alors même que la misère
grandit alors que les guerres se
multiplient alors que le climat se
dérègle comme
jamais FL est-ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec ce constat c'est pas une loi qui
empêchera les les hommes les familles de
fuir la misère la guerre les les
catastrophes climatiques oui parce que
tous les pays qui ont tenu des discours
extrêmement fermes dur qui ont bâti des
murs érigé des des grillages globalement
ont tous été confrontés en fait au
problèmes des flux migratoires et à leur
impossibilité de de gérer ça c'est le
premier élément c'est pas dissuasif de
construire un mur non parce que je je je
je pense qu'il y a rien de dissuasif
quand vous voulez traverser euh et et
changer de de vie les républiqu espagnol
qui devait traverser les Pyrénées
c'était à mon avis un mur tout aussi
important et et il y avait une volonté
derrière donc je pense que de la même
manière que cette ce mythe de l'appel
d'air il y a pas une bourse aux pays les
plus ou moins accueillants c'est les
passeurs qui peuvent jouer là-dessus
mais mais pas mais pas les que cela il
dit aussi accroissement de la misère et
il a de fait raison parce que la
sécuritisation des conditions d'accueil
d'expulsion et cetera évidemment va
créer une dégradation de des personnes
en attente ou en demande de
régularisation que le travail des
associations que le travail de la
justice va être considérablement
compliqué et enfin 3oème élément il n'y
a pas dans cette loi de mouvement
budgétaire suffisamment important pour
que le dispositif préfectoral policier
gendarmique puisse assurer une une vraie
muue du du dispositif une une grande
partie des ocutf des obligations de
quitter le territoire qui n'est pas
exécuté c'est d'abord et avant tout un
problème d'organ ation du dispositif
policier et gendarmique et ça je ne vois
pas les éléments qui vont véritablement
changer là-dessus donc je crois qu'on
est sur une loi qui a beaucoup de
marqueurs symbolique très fort et il
faut toujours se méfier quand on est
parlementaire de penser qu'on peut
arriver à régir la réalité avec une
décision législative il y a bien
d'autres choses derrière qui
conditionnent les résultats et des
succès ça c'est c'est une vraie question
parce qu'il y a eu on l'a dit plusieurs
fois sur ce plateau 30 textes depuis
1980 je disisais dans le dans le monde
117e loi depuis 1945 et la vraie
question c'est celle que que posait
Florent vadio c'est la capacité à
appliquer on peut durcir les lois
éternellement si on les applique pas à
quoi ça sert et et je vous poserai la
question de la réaction de l'opinion
face à ça notamment mais je crois aussi
que il y a euh vous vous parliez d'image
mais mais c'est c'est la réalité
c'est-à-dire que sur l'immigration en
réalité on travaille bien plus sur les
instincts sur les émotions de la
population et je crois que cette loi-là
ne déroge absolument pas à la rêg
notamment avec cette notion de choix de
l'immigration c'est son des lois de
posture plus que d'efficacité pardon
vous interrom ce sont des lois à mon
avis un peu idéologiques c'est-à-dire
que on essaie de de de parler de choix
de l'immigration mais encore une fois on
a carrément abandonné le terme vous
parlez du terme de s papier mais on a
carrément abandonné le terme
d'immigration on parle de migration
puisqu'on a affaire à des populations
qui n'ont plus de de d'État d'attach et
d'état d'accueil parce que elle migre
dans tout le monde tellement il y aura
de la migration climatique
internationale du fait des des
dégradations économiques de la guerre et
cetera donc je crois en effet que on est
ici sur un tout petit bout de la
lorniette et qu' il faut pas oublier en
effet que il y a un problème d'exécution
alors de là à dire en effet comme vous
le dites que il y a une déconnexion
entre la loi et son exécution c'est un
peu le problème de toutes les lois de
toute façon parce que ce sont deux
stades différents de l'exécution mais
c'est particulièrement vrai pour
l'immigration où en fait on se rend
compte que c'est vraiment un problème de
volonté politique d'arriver à afficher
des choses et ensuite agir sur le
terrain il y a il y a vraiment une
politique du chiffre qui fait que
aujourd'hui si on a le sentiment que
l'immigration est plus présente dans les
préoccupations c'est aussi parce qu'on
la voit plus parce que l'État est tout
simplement plus noyé par ces questions
c'est intéressant parce que c'est
vraiment une préoccupation du ministre
de l'Intérieur il y a a la semaine
dernière dans une chronique li vous nous
aviez présenté finalement sa stratégie
de communication il tweetit tous les
jours pour donner des résultats fait le
nombre de personnes expulsé ça continue
ça continue ça continue j'ai regardé il
a tweeté juste avant que l'émission de
commence vers 16h 16h 17h tous les jours
il a tweeté hier il tweet alors il donne
des initiales l'âge des personnes de
quoi elles sont accusées coupables et
puis il dit elle est rentrée dans son
pays on l'a raccompagné voilà tous les
jours tous les jours donc il faudrait
commencer à compter depuis le premier
tweet oui hein parce que je pense que là
les eqtf fonctionnent d'après le
ministre de l'Intérieur d'après le
ministre de l'Intérieur jean-el Levi
c'est intéressant cette stratégie de
communication parce que c'est c'est pour
contrer justement une critique ou un
ressenti peut-être d'une partie de
l'opinion que on a beau voter des des
lois la situation ne change pas vraiment
peut-être que je caricature un peu mais
oui oui bah c'est le reproche qui est
effectué souvent à l'égard des
responsables politiques
vous prenez des décisions façon au final
ne sont pas complètement appliqué c'est
le cas par exemple concernant
l'immigration c'est le cas également
concernant la justice on voit bien que
globalement les Français disent enfin
vous êtes bien gentil il y a une
personne qui a été condamnée à 3 ans de
prison mais on sait dès le départ que
elle ne fera pas ces 3 ans de prison et
queil y aura des aménagements de peine
et peut-être même qu'elle n'ira jamais
ou qu'il y aura jamais vraiment
d'incarcération à proprement parler je
penseintérieur a bien étudié ce que vous
venez dire parce que dans ces tweets on
retrouve exactement cela de quoi elles
sont
coupables elles ont été condamnées et
quand elles ont été reconduites
absolument et donc donc donc l'idée de
se dire que en fait on n'est pas
uniquement face à une attente de parole
qui serait en terme d'orientation
globale on veut une parole qui soit
performative c'est-à-dire que derrière
cela il y ait une application qui soit
une application réelle et d'ailleurs ça
dépasse le strict cadre de la question
migratoire ou de la question de
l'application des des obligations de
quitter de territoire français parce
Queen fait on se dit il y a trop souvent
en fait des postures qui sont pris de la
part des responsables politiques et au
final il décr bilise leurs propos parce
que par la suite il y a pas d'éléments
qui apparaissent comme étant concret ou
en tout cas ils sont dépassés parce que
comme vous l'avez indiqué les moyens
financiers ou les moyens humains sont
pas forcément complètement à la hauteur
des aspirations des citoyens bon cette
stratégie de communication elle est
efficace ça fait deux fois qu'on en
parle dans l'émission Florent votre avis
là-dessus d'abord Gérald Darman ne
poursuit pas que la démonstration de son
efficacité comme ministre de l'Intérieur
donc ceci peut expliquer cela ensuite
vou dire qu'il a d'autres ambitions et
d'autres objectifs der dis donc je me
permets de le reprendre et il semblait
très déçu de ne pas être à l'hôtel de
matigon donc je je pense qu'il il a
laissé suffisamment d'indice de ce point
de vue là et puis par ailleurs cette
communication elle est en réalité
extrêmement brutale dans son effet parce
que peut-on réellement croire qu'il y a
aussi peu d'qtf à exécuter en France
pour que le ministre puisse en tweeter
10 par jour 100 par jour c'est une vaste
plaisanterie donc c'est c'est
effectivement pourquoi il y en a combien
à votre avis alors j'ai pas les chiffres
exacts mais en tout cas on est à
plusieurs milliers donc je je pense que
le ministre va avoir du mal à dans ses
activités quotidiennes à à écluser
toutes les OQTF ne serait-ce qu'en
quelques semaine donc c'est une volonté
de démonstration qui en fait continue de
polariser le débat sur les questions
d'immigration et qui en fait n'appelle
pas à la réflexion mais appelle au
spontanéisme et plus on flatte ce
spontanéisme en fait plus on on on on
arrive à à résumer les choix migratoires
avec du bon sens qui n'est en fait pas
du bon sens l'exemple que je voudrais
citer c'est sur l'immigration étudiante
il y a eu un tour de vie sur
l'immigration étudiante et on trouve ça
tout à fait très bien parce que il faut
pas qu'il viennent et puis en même temps
quand on voit l'affaiblissement de la
présence de la France en Afrique on voit
qu'il y a un mouvement des élites
africaines qui ne viennent plus étudier
en France qui vont étudier dans d'autres
pays qui les accueillent à bras ouvert
et aujourd'hui par ex il y a une caution
qui a été ajoutée dans le texte il faut
donc payer une caution gager l'argent
d'une caution en cas de fraude tout ça
en fait créer un sur un bon sens en
pensant restreindre le le l'immigration
étudiante en fait cond a des effets qui
déclassent la France sur les
destinations étudiantes et et
scientifiques dans le monde donc je
pense qu'il faut se méfier de cette
polarisation qui en fait flatte de
villes instinct et ne permet pas
d'aborder des sujets d'une rare
complexité de manière très très très
digne alors on parle les uns et les
autres du ministre de l'intérieur on va
l'entendre tout de suite il se prépare
maintenant à la bataille de l'Assemblée
nationale le texte il sera présenté à
partir du 11 décembre c'est texte qui
est essentiel pour les français pour
réguler l'immigration pour forcer à une
meilleure intégration dans ce texte de
loi par exemple il y a l'idée que
désormais pour Pirir un titre de séjour
en France il faut passer un examen de
français est-ce que vous pensez que des
députés peuvent voter contre quelque
chosees comme ça aujourd'hui il y a 4000
étrangers délinquants que je ne peux pas
expulser parce que la loi me l'interdit
je demande qu'on modifie ça comment
peut-on refuser ça au ministre de
l'Intérieur dans le contexte dans lequel
nous sommes mais je suis là pour
discuter on peut pas à la fois envoyer
une majorité relative à l'Assemblée
nationale et demander au ministre de
l'intéur de ne pas discuter moi je suis
un homme ouvert de dialogue discutons et
j'ai qu' jours 3 semaines un mois plus
il faut pour trouver un compromis avec
les parlementair et bien effectivement
latia ça va sans doute se terminer par
une commission mixte paritaire
certainement ça va durer très longtemps
Thomas il le sait c'est pour ça qu'il
dit je suis un homme de dialogue un
homme ouvert discutons parce qu'il sait
que ce qu'il attend va être très
compliqué géraldin juste pour planter le
décor je vous propose deux extraits
d'interview d'abord Roger Koui sénateur
LR et puis Olivier ver le porte-parole
du gouvernement écoutez d'abord
Roger
pas de victoire je parlerai de ce que
c'est une reculade je demande simplement
à ma famille politique d'être cohérente
notre crédibilité elle tient à ça
pendant des mois mes amis politiques et
ils ont raison ont dit qu'il seraiit
intransigent je le serai intransigent au
fond je ne fais qu'appliquer ce qui a
été demandé alors c'était par Roger vous
l'avez vu c'est évident peut-être qu'on
l' retrouvé peut-être qu'on peut écouter
Roger on va l'écouter tout de suite jour
d'aujourd'hui alors après on verra ce
qui se passe à l'Assemblée pour de bon
mais au jour d'aujourd'hui entre ce que
demandent les républicains ce que
demande le rassemblement national ce que
demande LFI ce que demande le PS et
cetera à l'Assemblée je ne vois pas
comment on sort un texte en tout cas un
texte cohérent donc soit le gouvernement
fait du 493 et reprend ce qu'il souhait
dans son texte et j'espère que s'il fait
du 493 il reprendra un certain nombre de
mesures issus du Sénat soit on arrive à
quelque chose et il y a pas de 49 3 et
il y aura une commission mixte paritaire
sera un bras de fer lourd difficile
parce que par définition nous ne
cèderons pas voilà nous ne céderont pas
ça c'est très important de l'entendre
cette phrase parce que par exemple une
des mesures totem du Sénat c'est la
suppression de l'Ame l'aide médicale
d'État et sur l'ame Roger kucci et les
autres ont dit nous ne céderons pas on
va écouter maintenant ce qu'on disait
Olivier verrand ce matin il y a une
mission qui rendra ses conclusions d'ici
le 2 ou 3 décembre qui permettra de
regarder il a lieu ou non de d'améliorer
ou de toiletter certains dispositifs en
lien avec la me comme je l'avais fait
moi quand j'étais ministre il y a 2 ans
d'ailleurs on le fait de façon régulière
mais on garde la M me et ce qui va se
passer dans les prochains jours dans les
prochaines semaines ce sera une bonne
illustration d'un gouvernement qui ne
dispose que d'une majorité relative à
l'Assemblée B exactement donc les LR ne
vont pas céder le gouvernement veut
garder laame mais au milieu il a
l'Assemblée et donc à l'Assemblée Gérald
armanin on on fait que de répéter ce
terme en même temps en même temps mais
évidemment Thomas que Gérald amanin va
flatter l'aile gauche de la macronie on
oublie souvent qu'il y a une aile gauche
mais elle existe et à l'Assemblée elle
est bien présente donc il va devoir
c'est vrai dialoguer et peut-être aller
voir les députés LR c'est ce qu'il
espère les plus modérés pour réussir à
les convaincre ce qui est intéressant
c'est de regarder encore une fois
comment Gérald darada en parle il dit
par exemple que le Sénat alors il sent
bien sûr qu'il sen glorifie hein il dit
que le Sénat a adopté ce texte qu'il l'a
modifié mais que l'assemblée va
l'enrichir ça c'est son dernier tweet
voyez-vous donc on comprend que toutes
les subtilités de langage que finalement
ce n'est pas le texte que le
gouvernement voulait au départ que
l'assemblée va aussi l'enrichir dit-il
et donc on va voir on va voir quel ton
auront les discussions très vite et on
l'évoqué tout à l'heure il y a aussi ses
ambitions pour 2027 qui pèsent dans la
balance bah oui puisque si Gérald
harmanin réussit à obtenir un compromis
c'est ce qu' veut hein évidemment c'est
l'objectif premier du ministre de
l'Intérieur ce sera un avantage
conséquent pour une candidature pour
2027 et alors le problème Thomas c'est
que rien ne dit que ellisabeth born la
première ministre a envie de faire ce
cadeau à ministre avec qui elle a des
relations professionnel c'est le terme
qui est employé par Gérald Arman moi je
dirais compliqué voilà et en politique
vous savez c'est souvent dans son camp
qui est le danger donc il faut faire
attention
dernière question latia pourrait-elle la
première ministre utiliser le 493 pour
faire passer ce texte quand on interroge
Matignon on nous dit on finit par nous
dire qu'effectivement c'est pour
l'instant ce qui est sur la table
c'est-à-dire que ellizabeth vorn ne veut
prendre aucun risque et donc fera
adopter sans vote ce test on verra bien
on verra si un compromis est trouvé hein
et on verra aussi si c'est le 493 est
appliqué quel texte va passer Thomas
est-ce que toutes les modifications
justement modification je reprends le
terme
apporté par le Sénat seront dans le
texte définitif on verra ça qui sera
négocié sûrement en commission mixte
paritaire an Charl bizina on rappelle
que l'usage du
493 est limité alors sauf pour les
textes budgétaires très bien c'est c'est
quand même une cartouche que
qu'Élisabeth borne pourrait griller pour
vous sur ce texte immigration alors en
effet on a un article 493 limité depuis
2008 qui nous dit un texte par session
et une session c'est presque que toute
une année
universitaire qui amène à ce que ça
devienne un outil particulièrement
précieux alors une petite querelle entre
constitutionnalistes est en train d'être
d'ailleurs sur le fait de savoir si
cette cartouche n'est pas déjà grillée
étant donné que le 493 a été actionné il
n'y a pas plus tard qu' hier sur la loi
de programmation des finances publiques
qui je le rappelle n'est pas une loi de
finance donc peut-être même que cette
cartouche est désagrillée sans que
matigon s'en soit vraiment rendu compte
néanmoins en tout cas sur la question de
la loi immigration on peut se rendre
compte à quel point si c'est un mar cur
idéologique le 493 peut être un d'un
usage un peu risqué parce que comme vous
le disiez il faut choisir un texte il
faut choisir lequel mais la commission
mixte paritaire elle est tout aussi
minée pour le gouvernement parce que si
la commission mixte paritaire échoue
c'est l'Assemblée nationale qui a le
dernier mot donc on est sûr de dire
adieu au compromis comment elle est
composé cette commission mixte paritaire
est-ce que vous pouvez nous le rappeler
alors SEP députés se sénateurs qui
représente on va dire la coloration
politique de chacune des assemblées donc
on a quand même une bonne assise DLR
mais les LR ne sont eux-mêmes pas
unanimes puisque on le sait il y a des
LR de
l'assembé les tiraillements internes
entre le le Sénat et mê que une toute
microscopique assemblée de cette
personnes des deux assemblées peut déjà
poser des problèmes de compromis surtout
sur un texte aussi clivant on l'a dit
l'immigration c'est vraiment un marqueur
idéologique pour chacune des formations
politiques qui plus est dans la période
que l'on les signateurs ont prévenu ils
ont dit en comion mixitaire de toute
façon nous ne saons rien rien oui alors
ça on va en parler avec mathiasz dans un
instant mais je voudrais qu'on qu'on se
concentre quelques minutes les uns et
les autres sur la personnalité du
ministre de l'Intérieur est-ce qu'il
tire profit genanel Levi de de cette
enfin dans les enquêtes de popularité
est-ce qu'il tire profit de cette
séquence ou pas benah au cours de la
dernière période oui il est devenu le
deuxième ministre qui bénéficiit de la
plus forte confiance de la part des
Français avec une évolution qui était
une
évolution logique mais peut-être pas
entièrement souhaitée de sa part
c'està-dire qu'il a très nettement
progressé chez les électeurs qui étaient
proches des républicains chez les
électeurs qui étaient proches du rass
ement national et dans un mê élan il
avait quelque peu baissé parmi le cœur
de l'électorat d'Emmanuel Macron et les
différentes dispositions qu'il avait pu
adopter et porter au cours du mois
d'octobre et où il y avait eu la
perception qu'on était face à un
ministre de l'Intérieur qui était
beaucoup plus en fait pour faire vite
dans la coerition que dans
l'accompagnement ou dans la réflexion
sur l'intégration avait raisonné
positivement en tout cas plus
positivement que par le passé à l'égard
de deux autres types d'électorat donc on
a aujourd'hui effec effectivement cette
petite marque de sa part qui fait que
depuis qu'il a pris position en disant
qu'il était non pas le candidat des
catégorie populaire mais pas loin qu'il
s'inscrivait autour des préoccupations
des Français qu'il allait s'intéresser
aux catégories populaires et qu'il a les
prendre à bras le corps la thématique de
l'immigration une progression justement
auprès de cette frange électorale ça se
traduirait pas forcément en tout cas
immédiatement en terme de comportement
électoral mais en tout cas euh on a des
Français qui ont entendu qu' ont vu qui
ont reçu 5 sur C le message en tout cas
de la part de ceux probablement qu'il
souhaitaent qu'il l'entendent et puis
ceux qui sont un peu plus gênés par
rapport à cela ont porter une forme de
distance par rapport à ce qui a pu être
indiqué de la part de de Géral harmanin
il y a peut-être un aspect je pense qu'
a peut-être pas suffisamment été évoqué
c'est que la thématique de l'immigration
n'a quasiment pas été évoquée par
Emmanuel Macron dans le cadre de sa
campagne électorale pas plus que c l'
avait été en 2017 et c'est pas la
première fois que la majorité
présidentielle se fissure autour de la
question migratoire vous avez fait
référence tout à l'heure en fait à la
loi qui était portée à l'époque par
Monsieur colon déjà à cette époque- làà
il y avait une tension entre guillemets
l'aile gauche et l'aile droite les
députés disant nous sommes comptables de
ce qui a été indiqué dans le cadre de la
campagne présidentielle la thématique
migratoire n'a pas été évoquée en tant
que tel de la part du président de la
républiqueit dans la press il l'a fait
un peu dans la presse mais on peut pas
dire en fait en tout cas c'était pas un
gros axe de campagneême temps sa
campagne était presque une non campagne
donc dire ça comm ça on peut le dire
également tout cas peut-être encore
moins sur la question migratoire que sur
les autres aspects et c'est une des
raisons pour lesquell aujourd'hui on a
des députés qui se sentent encore plus
libres de pouvoir afficher encore et
nettement leur désaccords en dehors de
leurs valeurs ou de leur sensibilité
politique d'origine ouais vous vous vous
disiez tout à l'heure parliez de la
marge de manœuvre que Gérald armanin
c'est donné en quelque sorte c'est c'est
c'est c'est votre analyse en acceptant
que le texte soit à ce point durci au
Sénat marge de manœuvre justement dans
ces négociations avec avec les députés
macronistes c'est ça oui parce que les
sénateurs le savent très bien et c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça qu'il communiquent
beaucoup plus le texte est caricatural
plus il est amendable et là ils sont
quand même allés très loin je je je je
pense que ils ont fait preuve d'un
défaut d'imagination parce que sinon il
ils auraient inventer d'autres choses
donc lorsque Roger carucci dit que ils
ne céderont pas lorsque Bruno rotao
prévient en fait il durcit les
conditions d'un négociation mais ils
savent parfaitement qu'ils vont devoir
céder il n'est pas de leur avantage
qu'il y ait un 493 sur le le texte ils
ont tout intérêt à justement engranger
une victoire politique donc leur leur
intérêt c'est que la commission mixte
paritaire soit conclusive donc je pense
que euh ils sont pas trop mal
représentés vous l'avez dit au sein de
de la commission mixte paritaire ils
vont accepter nécessairement des
ajustements et c'est pour ça que Géral
armmanin il est assez serein c'est aussi
pour ça qu'il a annoncé qu'il dégageait
son emploi du temps pour assister à
toutes les réunions de commission qui
seraiit présent auprès du président
Houlier or le président Houlier est on
peut le dire président de la Commission
de qui incarne on va dire l' gauche de
la macronie à l'Assemblée c'est je pense
le diamètre opposé de Gérald Arman en
tout cas il a orchestré cela dans
plusieurs tribunes dans Libération avec
une partie de la gauche parlementaire
tribune commune signée avec des
communistes des écologistes des
socialistes effectivement onvens de
cette photo à la line de libération avec
un certain nombre de leaders Fabien
Roussel Sacha oulier et et d'autres qui
se serraent la main avec un restaurateur
et et l'un de ses salariés sans papier
exactement et donc le président Houlier
a mis en scène son son ancrage à gauche
depuis déjà plusieurs semaines il on va
voir s'il maîtrise sa commission s'il
est un président respecté qui est en en
capacité de mettre en minorité le
gouvernement car je rappelle que on se
focalise beaucoup sur le texte de séance
publique mais le texte qui sera examiné
en séance publique l'aura d'abord été et
amendé en commission des lois et donc
c'est là dans ce premier scénacle où les
négociations peuvent avoir lieu que
Géral peut commencer à avant le 11
décembre hein décembre c'est la sé
publique et le 27 novembre c'est le
début de l'examen en commission des lois
donc on va voir si un Sacha ou est un
président puissant deux si géralde
armanin est prêt à des concessions même
avec des des sagesses et donc
effectivement quels sont les quel est le
gras en quelque sorte que le ministre
est prêt à lâcher sur ce texte
d'ailleurs géralin devait rencontrer
Sacha ou aujourd'hui on a cherché à
vérifier on a pas eu la la confirmation
d'un éventuel déjeuner ou d'une ou d'une
rencontre mais anine Bina c'est c'est
presque un par un en tout cas c'est ce
qu'a annoncé le ministre de l'Intérieur
il va essayer d'aller convaincre les les
députés pas seulement de sa majorité
d'ailleurs côtér un par un il y a
Emmanuel Macron quand même he qui quand
il était ministre de l'Économie l'a fait
l'a fait savoir s'est fait connaître
d'ailleurs du public pour cela parce
qu'il est allé convaincre les députés un
par un ce qui n'avait pas empêché manuel
Vals char beina de de d'utiliser le 493
utilis un 43 de sécurisation he je
rappelle on n'est pas à l'abri d'une
Élisabeth borne qui emploie les mêmes
termes et qui et qui n'offre pas à
Gérald haranin le cadeau d'un d'un d'un
d'une loi qui qui qui passe finalement
grâce à un accord en commission mix
paritaire on verra bien bien sûr et et
dans la référence de Létitia moi je
voyais Michel Rocard parce que les
alliances en allant convaincre député
par député c'est le quotidien de la
majorité relative c'est-à-dire que vous
êtes obligé de faire du service à la
personne en quelque sorte et Gérald
hermanin ici à tout intérêt en effet à
déjà convaincre dans sa base avant
d'aller se frotter euh au chaudron du
groupe les républicain qui là quand même
va aussi poser beaucoup de problèmes de
cohérence à ce parti mais aussi de
cohérence à ce nouveau texte de
l'Assemblée nationale qui gagnerait
évidemment à ne pas être trop éloigné de
celui du Sénat pour des raisons de
cohérence politique mais je crois que
sur une loi immigration en effet c'est
tellement facile d'être caricatural que
trouver du compromis c'est aussi très
politiquement risqué parce que il ne
faut pas qu'il perde la face et il faut
que cette macronie du en même temps qui
a disparu ici est un sens pourquoi avoir
été aussi dur au Sénat si on est prêt à
finalement en dire une chose et son
inverse en quelques jours c'est
exactement la critique qui va lui être
fa par opposition qui est déjà
d'ailleurs la critique qui lui est faite
par l'opposition sénatoriale il faut
aussi considérer que c'est c'est c'est
le jeu du du bicamérisme que des textes
soient amender négocier discuter et
évolue néanmoins je crois que l'opinion
qui justement est assez mais vous nous
le confirmerez qui est assez tranché sur
ces questions d'immigration elle va
avoir du mal à être mise d'accord sur un
en même temps en matière migratoire et
précisément faire passer aux Français
d'abord un texte aussi dur et ensuite un
texte assoupli ça va être difficile pour
leur faire comprendre quelle est la
musique sur laquelle ce gouvernement
entend vraiment jouer parce que je crois
que c'est si c'est un 493 qui se joue
par exemple c'est vraiment une question
d'ADN politique et bien il va falloir
comprendre quel est le cœur de ce texte
ou alors vous parliez de caricature
justement les les sénateurs LR refusent
d'être caricaturés en tout cas c'est ce
que disait sur les métiers en tenstion
le sénateur du rô François Noël buffet
cet après-midi juste avant le vote
solennel au Sénat fameux article 3 nous
sommes contre l'intégration par le
travail c'est ce que vous dites àtu tête
de partout on na jamais dit ça on a
simplement dit que le travail
l'intégration par le travail et pour
obtenir un titre de séjour pour
travailler dans les mé les métiers en
tension devait répondre à un certain
nombre de règles que nous n'avons pas
voulu ce que prévoyait l'article 3 avoir
une régularisation massive et
automatique parce qu'elle constituait un
appel d'air considérable et oui nous
devons le confirmer et que nous avons
changé le dispositif avec un moyen
confié une procédure confiée au préfet
dans le cadre de mission exceptionnelle
au séjour et je crois que nous avons
bien fait et pour ceux qui nous
regardent ce qu'il faut qu'ils sacheent
c'est que les étrangers ayant un contrat
de travail dans des métiers en tension
pourront être régularisés sur le
territoire national par le préfet à la
condition qu'ils en fassent
naturellement leur demande au titre de
l'admission exceptionnelle au séjour et
que la réalité du travail soit contrôlé
et j'accueille Mathias Arz bonsoir
Mathias bienvenue sur le plateau de de
sens public justement pour détailler le
rôle des sénateurs et députés les
républicains absolument on prend les
mêmes et on recommence après euh les
retraites et bien il semblerait que ce
soit le retour de la friture sur la
ligne entre le Palais Bourbon et le
Palais du Luxembourg chez leslr les
Sénateurs de droite qui ont réussi tout
de même à convaincre leurs alliés
centristes sur un certain nombre de
points pour faire dégager une majorité
et ainsi euh voter un texte he on l'a vu
tout à l'heure dans le sujet de d'audre
vuetaz et bien leur patron ici au Sénat
Bruno retaillot estime que c'est une
victoire c'est un bras de faire gagné
avec l'exécutif ce qui n'est pas le cas
d'une partie des députés LR avec à leur
tête un Aurélien
Pradier je ne parlerai pas de victoire
je parlerai de ce que c'est une reculade
je demande simplement à ma famille
politique d'être cohérente notre
crédibilité elle tient à ça pendant des
mois mes amis politiques et ils ont
raison ont dit qu'il seraient
intransigent je le serai intransigent au
fond je ne fais qu'appliquer ce qui a
été demandé je vais être honnête on a
cru que Roger kucci allait apparaître
mais mais tout est revenu dans l'ordre
merci à tous qu'en pense Bruno Raillot
et bien imaginez que sa propre famille
politique puisse storpillaer le texte
pour une reculade ça l'a bien fait rire
c'est le cas de le dire voici sa
réaction c'était au micro de Flora
sauvage et de audre
viutaz c'est qu'ils ont pas très très
bien lu le texte il y a rien de commun
entre l'ancien article 3 et d'autres
articles d'abord parce que nous c'est
pas opposable ensuite on durcit même les
conditions de la circulaire Vals on a un
dispositif antifraude non non on a dans
ce texte là les marqueurs de la droite
que nous avons fait passer sur tant
d'autres sujets
je je pense que jamais la droite n'a
voté tout ce que nous avons voté nous
ici au Sénat c'est clairement plus le
texte de Gérald Arman puisque il en
contenait 27 articles il en contient
désormais 96 articles c'est bien notre
texte le texte de la majorité sénatorial
on sait le sénateur vandéen très attaché
à son texte un Bruno rotillot qui a
prévenu si la substance change trop son
groupe n'aidera pas à ce qu'une
commission mixte paritaire soit
conclusive pire si 493 il y a et bien il
a appelé dimanche ses homologues de
l'Assemblée nationale a déposé une
motion de censure contre le gouvernement
et le parti le parti LR dans tout ça
alors son champion ou plutôt le champion
du patron des républicains Laurent
vquier était justement convié à la
réunion de groupe des députés à
l'Assemblée nationale ce mardi c'était
une première he depuis les élections
législative de 2022 et bien il a comme
en Phil Thomas thèse antithèse synthèse
le président de la Région auverne ronalp
a surpris hein son audience selon
plusieurs de nos confrères qui ont pu
avoir vent des teneurs des échanges
Laurent VO aurait en effet déclaré on
est très aligné avec le Sénat la seule
question c'est veut-on poursuivre l'en
même temps ou assumer un tournant clair
le Sénat a fait passer un tournant à ce
texte le son circulé il y a rien à voir
merci beaucoup Mathias pour toutes ces
information jean-dianiel léi est-ce que
Laurent vquier a le pouvoir de souder
les députés LR sur ce texte parce que
c'est on se souvenait de de du pataquais
sur les retraites est-ce qu'on est-ce
qu'on va vers un bis répéti je me trompe
peut-être mais je pense que Laurent
voquer pas plus que qui que ce soit a la
possibilité de pouvoir avoir une
incidence sur les députés LR on voit
bien façon on l'a vu au moment de la
réforme des retraites que on pensait dès
le départ que globalement le groupe
était sououé que on s'orienta
tranquillement vers un vote de la part
des des députés LR que globalement le
493 était quand même extrêmement loin
derrière nous et puis au fur à mesure
qu'on s'est approché des chances on a vu
à quel point chacun est venu globalement
sur sur ses positions et qui plus est
comme on sait et comme le disait ltia
tout à l'heure c'est toujours au sein de
son camp politique il faut être amené
probablement à se méfier qu'il y a des
enjeux sous-jacents qui vont pas être
uniquement liés à la question de
l'immigration et qui vont peut-être
amener des postur et parmi la
soixantaine de députés LR des
positionnements autour de pasaniquement
ce qui se passe à l'heure actuelle en
2023 mais commencer à préparer 2027 avec
des postures qui vont être soit plus l
soit soit soit plus dur soit plus douce
à l'égard du du du du projet de loi tel
qu' peut être proposé dans le cadre de
de l'Assemblée nationale donc je je je
suis pas certain que Laurent voquier
plus que d'autres personnes est la
capacité de pouvoir mettre toutes tous
les députés exactement dans la même
direction ou on va on va voir revenir
l'expression des députés autant
entrepreneurs qu'on a déjà employé un
certain nombre de fois sur ce sur ce
plateau charine Bina on n' pas encore
parlé du rassemblement national dans ce
débat et pourtant enfin moi le sentiment
que j'ai c'est on aurait presque pu
titrer tout le monde court après le RN
quoi sur ce sur ce texte immigration je
crois que c'est tout l'enjeu de cette
posture c'est qu'on ne l'entende pas
précisément le rassemblement national
puisque on l'avait dit de toute façon
l'immigration est un marqueur
idéologique de on va dire même dans
l'Europe proche des groupes les plus à
droite des cénacles politiques donc a
priori sans parler de toute façon les
Français identifie assez clairement que
c'est un cœur de cible en matière de
thématique néanmoins sur le choix
on a un groupe LR qui ici fait quelque
chose d'un peu paradoxal dans le sens où
il a le sentiment d'aller plus loin que
le groupe rassemblement national qui lui
a fait savoir qu'il voterait le texte
alors que petite loi mais on la votera
le groupe LIR du Sénat a l'air de tenir
encore plus à quelque chose de plus dur
donc c'est vrai qu'on a on a deux
postures très différentes entre les LR
du Sénat et les LR de l'Assemblée
nationale et j'ajouterai aussi que on a
une nouvelle aujourd'hui qui ne nous
fait pas forcément comprendre la posture
de compromis adoptée par l'ELR qui est
le fait qu'ericotti refuse de finalement
participer aux rencontres de Saint-Denis
bis et bien pour lesquels le président
de la République on le rappelle avait
ouvert la voix question à l'immigration
et même à un référendum sur ces
questions donc on voit bien quelque part
que le groupe LR est fort de sa position
de groupe incontournable dans cette
majorité relative du Sénat et dans cette
dans cette majorité relative de
l'Assemblée nationale et dans ce jeu au
Sénat parce que finalement je crois que
peut-être un peu tôt cette fois-ci le
gouvernement a droitisé sans trop de
complexe son discours et c'est donc
évidemment du pain béni pour le groupe
LR et le rassemblement national qui lui
n'a même plus de carte à jouer puisque
tout se fait sans qu'il ait besoin de
parler mais il l'a certainement pas fait
très rapidement à l'aveugle c'est-à-dire
que depuis 2022 depuis l'élection
présidentielle on dit que la France a
basculé à droite ça a été vraiment un
constat fait et partagé par tous les
observateurs donc c'est une France
normalement acquise à la cause sur le
papier oui sur le papier oui papier an
Vadi dernier mot le débat ce premier
débat est quasiment terminé sur le le le
rassemblement national on l'a dit Marine
Le Pen alors dans la première version
elle parlait d'une petite loi pas pas
sur la version retravaillée par le par
le Sénat mais on pourrait en faire un
peu de politiicion mais se retrouve avec
une situation où le RN vote la loi mais
pas les députés voyez ce que je veux
dire avec avec quel impact dans
l'opinion al d'abord je ne crois pas à
cette possibilité parce que je pense que
le texte est suffisamment technique euh
buissonnant pour que en fait on laisse
des victoires symboliques au Sénat et
qu'on change des curseurs et qui
permettqu quelques curur qui seront pas
centraux et donc ça permettra
d'ion réinttroduire l'aide médicale
d'État en maintenant le la dénomination
aide médicale
d'urgence franchement le débat public ne
verra pas véritablement de de différence
par ailleurs Marine Le Pen elle joue un
élément très simple c'est que elle n'a
pas envie de griller beaucoup de
cartouches pour qu'elle ne se voit pas
en quelque sorte dépossédé pour la
prochainne présidentielle et elle
continue sa respectabilisation en votant
les textes qui sont utiles à la vie des
français donc en réalité elle peut
continuer medzovocher ce discours là il
y aura pas de difficulté les
républicains de de l'Assemblée nationale
ils vont être beaucoup plus clivé parce
que je pense qu'effectivement Laurent
vquier n'a aucune incidence en revanche
leurs électeurs ont une incidence et ils
ont été élus sur une franche beaucoup
plus à droite qu'Emmanuel Macron donc il
va falloir qu'ils expliquent comment ce
dernier carré de députés sur un
électorat bien plus à droite qu'Emmanuel
Macron refuse un texte issu du Sénat
l'équation est quasi impossible pour eux
donc je pense que ils ont raison de se
rebuffer maintenant parce qu'ils auront
moins de possibilités à l'avenir merci
beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir participé
à ce débat et et à bientôt sur sur
Public Sénat